une morale Déclin et les hommes bons ne font
rien le mal
s'épanouit une société qui ne veut pas apprendre
du passé est
condamnée nous ne devons jamais oublier notre histoire
nous ne devons jamais abaisser notre
Dieu, il vous devenez l'homme le plus puissant
du
pays, je crois que lorsque  un homme
devient membre de ce Bureau, il doit
se comporter de manière à éliminer la
moindre possibilité de critique quant à
sa conduite M. Tolson J'ai besoin de quelqu'un en qui
je peux avoir confiance Je veux que tu sois mon
homme numéro deux, tu comprends, j'ai besoin que
tu imagines  si chaque citoyen de ce
pays était identifiable de manière unique par
le motif sur ses doigts, imaginez à quelle
vitesse nous pourrions les retrouver s'ils
commettaient un
crime, vous vous souvenez du dossier que nous avons créé
sur sa femme, Mme Roosevelt, pourriez-vous m'en faire
une copie, s'il vous plaît, est-ce légal
parfois  vous devez contourner un peu les règles
afin d'assurer la sécurité de votre pays,
veuillez me laisser les transcriptions ici,
n'hésitez pas et partagez-les avec
votre frère, M. Kennedy, faites-lui savoir
que j'ai une copie de mon
propre président, il a peur de toute l'
admiration qu'il y a dans  le monde ne peut pas remplir l'
endroit où va l'amour, nous sommes les pécheurs
Edgar, nous tolérons l'anarchie dans le
pays à des groupes aux
proportions diaboliques, le sang est sur vos mains,
allez, quelles sont vos
qualifications exactes pour votre position de
leadership dans ce Bureau mon
qualifications monsieur, je ne sais plus à qui je
peux faire confiance, je vois à travers
vous, vous êtes un horrible
petit homme effrayé, sans cœur, vous n'aimerez pas une petite
fleur, sois forte, oui,
maman, il est temps que cette génération apprenne
même la différence entre le méchant et le héros.  les grands hommes peuvent être
[Musique]
corrompus